[Music]
hi there and welcome to our 10th episode
on sre and devops my name is Seth and
I'm a developer advocate at Google
focused on infrastructure and operations
and I'm Liz a site reliability engineer
at Google where I teach Google cloud
customers how to build and operate
reliable services so I've just wrapped
up an incident and I definitely don't
want to have the same set of things
happen in the exact same ways what
should I do to learn so Liz you'll want
to conduct a blameless postmortem
or retrospective there are a few key
things that go into every retrospective
but there are a variety of ways of
collecting that information first you'll
need some basic metadata like what
systems were affected and what humans
were involved in that process right it
doesn't make sense to conduct a
post-mortem without involving everyone
who played a part right and then you'll
need to start assembling any records
that you have and start to begin
understanding a timeline like how did we
find out about the event when did we
start responding what mitigations did we
deploy either temporarily or permanently
when did the incident actually conclude
and it's important to note that this is
a collaborative process initially the
draft is written by the incident
commanders but all participants
collaborate and add their relevant
information it's usually helpful to use
a collaborative tool like Google Docs
for this step I'm starting to understand
now why you emphasize the roles the
planning lead last time it's definitely
a lot easier to record things as you go
rather than having to piece everything
together after the fact and you'll also
need to understand what things you did
that you'll need to roll back or clean
up afterwards
things like temporarily increasing the
size of a VM or directing traffic away
from his own I can definitely see how it
would get expensive or risky if I didn't
put those back the way that I found them
but most importantly in the process
though is making sure that you have a
blameless culture ensuring that people
feel like they won't be faulted or fired
for the mistakes that they may have made
I definitely see how I'd be really
reluctant to say I messed up if I were
afraid of being fired or ridiculed
exactly and participating in a
post-mortem is a learning opportunity
for everyone involved including the
company not some kind of punishment and
it works best if your team can think
about the possibility of a
well-intentioned human
to cause a system failure as a bug in
the system not as a bug in the human
right you can't fix humans it's often
helpful to ask questions like what did
you know at the time or how did the
system behave as opposed to why did you
restart the process in order to avoid
putting people on the defensive right so
how do you actually organize this
information once you're collecting it
though so every organization has
different ways for communicating as I
said above at Google we tend to use
Google Docs and comments other
organizations may prefer something like
a live conference bridge with someone
taking notes in the background right
that makes sense and you've reminded me
by mentioning taking notes during an
audio-only conference bridge but it's
not really a great idea to during an
incident having audio-only conference
reduced because you have to have someone
record very detailed notes in order to
reconstruct what happened after the fact
but we haven't really gotten to anything
about how do we prevent the root cause
from happening again well be careful
there Liz remember that failures and
distributed systems almost never have a
single root cause it's usually more than
one contributing factor that's causing
an intersection or some kind of
cascading failure so you'll want to
write down everything that contributed
to this abnormal behavior instead of
just trying to identify the root cause
so what I should be focusing on is how
do I meet individual kinds of failures
and how do I prevent them from
intersecting in the same ways right and
then you'll want to keep track of that
is explicitly filing an issue in your
issue tracker of choice for each action
item so that you'll make sure to
prioritize it for the future and I can
definitely tag these things with a
post-mortem tag in my bug tracker so I
can see how at risk I am of repeat
outages based off of how many
high-priority items that I've checked
off and how many remain outstanding
exactly and you'll also want to capture
some overall themes like what went well
what went poorly and honestly what did
we just get lucky with I also imagine
that recognizing people that went above
and beyond and systems that worked well
and worked as designed is a good
positive motivator as well exactly and
one last key thing to keep track of once
you understand the incident in its
entirety is to write down machine
readable metadata so that you can track
improvements to your overall incident
response management process over time
such as you know decreasing the total
time to resolve incidents or knowing
whether a release
was involved or cascading failure or
config changes etc this can help you
identify meta patterns in your outages
and build either process or technology
to help prevent or mitigate those
incidents in the future and that's where
Google statistics come from that
approximately 70% of our outages are
from binary or configuration changes
because we've been recording that meta
data over the past seven years hopefully
these tips help you prepare for your
next incident and thanks to everyone for
watching this series so far please write
to us on Twitter if you have feedback or
suggestions for future topics thank you
for watching please be sure to like and
subscribe below
[Music]